today I'm going to be speaking with
Rachel Bernstein who's an educator
therapist author media and government
consultant and also host of the weekly
podcast in doctorate nation and for over
30 years has been treating former cult
members and their families victims of
malignant narcissists former
supremacists conspiracy theorists quite
quite a list uh Rachel I appreciate you
joining me today oh it's my pleasure
thanks for asking me to be on so I mean
before we get into some of the
nitty-gritty how did it happen that you
started I don't know if you would
necessarily call it a focus but that
that you started working in this
particular space with these types of
folks right yeah it is most definitely a
focus and it has remained so there was
someone in my family who got ensnared in
a particular cultic group so it was kind
of dinner table conversation and then
when I went off to college I had already
learned about some Cults that use front
names on college campuses to get people
off of college campuses and to kind of
just take them away and I saw them with
my own eyes and you know first when you
hear about culture thinking someone's
being a little paranoid and maybe
they're exaggerating and there it was
and then when I went on to become a
therapist I was noticing that there were
a lot of people who just didn't think
they existed and I thought I need to be
a resource I need to be able to be out
there to help people when they have had
this issue because it's very specific
when we talk about
um Cults for example to start with there
are dramatically different scenarios
when someone has already left the cult
and the support that they might need at
that point versus if someone is in the
cult and loved ones may be thinking more
of what is sometimes colloquially known
as an intervention can you talk about
whether you deal with both or more the
after the fact only
right so most of what I deal with is the
after the fact although I am involved in
some interventions these are
non-forcible conversational style
interventions it's important that people
know that so that they don't get afraid
of them that it's not at all that you're
you know pulling up in a van and putting
someone in something that's windowless
and taking them away yeah it really is
helping to educate them about what they
are involved in because people involved
in cults actually know the least about
them they have the least amount of
access to the information so all you're
doing is informing them about what's
true but I'd say about 70 of the people
I work with have been out sometimes for
a few days I mean I've had people show
up in my office as they left that day
um and others who have been out for
years and realize that they need help
because there are so many triggers that
have been implanted that they didn't
realize until they got triggered when
I've interviewed former white
supremacists for example one of the
trends is that when they reflect on how
they were originally sucked in they they
all tell a very similar story and it
doesn't mean it's the only story but at
least the ones I've spoken to have a
similar story which is sort of
opportunity caused by usually problems
at home often with absent parents or
abusive parents a sort of search for
meaning and inclusion from some kind of
group so sometimes there was bullying at
school it's it's sort of a
circumstantial in terms of the
environment that they're in that makes
them vulnerable to the recruitment of
some of these supremacists is that your
experience and also is it similar with
the people that get sucked into Cults
that may not be extremist in that same
way
right so that has been my experience as
well in addition to there is a timing
Factor so when people ask me what kind
of person gets involved in a cult
sometimes it is exactly that that
they're looking for something they're
looking for meaning they're looking for
connection Community for having a
purpose they're trying to find some
space for them in the world maybe in
kind of parallel universe because they
haven't found their way in mainstream
Society but
for a lot of people it's a timing issue
they are away from home for the first
time or they just went through a trauma
or they were just diagnosed with
something or they were just abused for
the first time and they're looking to
escape that so I think a lot of factors
actually play into it you've worked with
the FBI on some cases that maybe some in
our audience are are familiar with one
such case is the Branch Davidians in
Waco Texas and and the negotiations that
took place there can you talk a little
bit about
what is such a negotiation process like
what are the what are the principles
that are at play in such negotiations in
those situations
you know those are interesting times
certainly
um because there is something very
incendiary about the moment and so
you're kind of trying to beat the clock
what you find when you're dealing with
the FBI are really any kind of
government agency is that you're trying
to educate them about what's different
about this and how they need to interact
in a different way than they might be
thinking that doesn't always happen they
don't always listen unfortunately
um and but you can give your idea about
how to make sure that they don't make
people afraid of leaving by doing what
they're doing to get them to come out
I've been involved in a number of raids
not planning them necessarily but
helping with the aftermath and helping
with people who have been taken off
compounds with the Branch Davidians I
use the information that I knew about
what would make people scared of leaving
and to and I think to really make them
feel scared of the world which is what
unfortunately the ATF did
um by playing very loud music and making
them really feel overwhelmed and by kind
of proving the cult leader right about
the world unfortunately
um that then they stayed in but the
other information I used was from people
who had escaped before the fire
some of the families the parents the
children who had been able to get out
who were also guiding me about what they
thought would be the best sort of course
of action for the people still in it
sometimes they listen again and
sometimes not so much so you mentioned
you mentioned the the leaders
depending on which of which cult one is
talking about or extremist group
oftentimes the followers allow or maybe
accept is the better word
that their leaders play by a different
set of rules there's rules for the
followers and the leaders often don't
follow those very same rules now in
cases like maybe a Jim Jones and the
people's Temple it's he seems sort of
like as a deity almost and so that makes
it really easy to understand well like
if you're God or Godlike of course you
have a different set of rules that you
play by then we the followers play by
but not all of these Cults have leaders
that necessarily frame themselves in
this kind of deified way
in the non-overtly deifying Cults what
are the explanations or justifications
that the followers have for why the
rules they have to follow aren't the
rules that the leader has to follow
it's a great question uh it happens time
and time again and to make this very
relatable this is something that also
happens in relationships with
controllers and with malignant
narcissists where they can do whatever
they want and you can't question them
and they can have access to your
information or your passwords or your
you know ATM and they they can gain
everything and you have nothing you have
no power you can't get any of their
information but they can get all of
yours so it happens in these sort of
one-on-one these sort of dyad Cults too
within these relationships but going
back to the idea of Carlton why
permission is given
permission is given for everything when
it comes to the leader within a cult
um and that's actually why some people
start Cults because they love that they
love having the freedom to do or say
whatever they want and they love knowing
that the rules only apply to the
followers I mean it's sort of you know
the sociopath or the narcissistic
playground
um and you know they couldn't enjoy it
more unfortunately what happens when you
get involved in a system like this
is that there's kind of what I see is a
dual track of influence one is overt and
one is covert and the overt is here are
the teachings here's what we believe in
and here's what you need to do to be a
good follower the covert one is if you
question how things are run you will not
receive the benefit of this all of your
sacrifice will be for naught right your
time is going to be wasted if you are
questioning the fact that I have
44 rolls royces like with rajneesh and
you get nothing and you sleep on the
floor then that negativity is going to
get in the way of you receiving what I'm
trying to give you
um and you need to question yourself
people learn how to turn the focus
inward within a cult and they question
themselves for doubting and doubting and
being negative being angry about
anything or resenting anything in occult
is considered really really awful and
it's going to be counterproductive to
what you're trying to get by being there
so you think you're working against
Yourself by having critical thinking
it's a fascinating kind of way of
getting into gaslighting when I've
spoken to experts on conspiracy theories
sometimes the idea comes up of like more
destructive or dangerous conspiracy
theories versus one ones that are sort
of like more benign and sometimes there
will be this contrast where it's like
you know some of the anti-semitic
conspiracy theories that lead people to
seek out and do violence against Jewish
people very dangerous on the other hand
believing the Earth is flat not so
dangerous and to some degree every
conspiracy theory expert that I talked
to says yes in the overt sense it's true
that one is much more dangerous than the
other at the same time rarely is there
only one conspiratorial belief these
things open doors to more and more
extreme beliefs and so we should be
careful to say this one is totally
benign we don't need to worry about it
when we think about that as applied to
Cults are there what we might call not
very dangerous cults like for example I
read an article not long ago about how
CrossFit or like Peloton or Soul cycle
they have a lot of the elements on paper
of a cult but it's not really dangerous
in the way that a lot of these others
are can you talk a little bit about that
and kind of categorizing these
right so yeah there are some cultic
groups that are more dangerous than
others and undoubtedly and it all
depends upon the leader it depends where
the leader wants to take it and what the
leader needs in terms of ego
aggrandizement if they want to just test
you to see what you're willing to do for
them because it makes them feel powerful
then they will sometimes push you to the
brink they'll push you to the point
where it's not healthy for you it's
actually dangerous for you just because
they want to see you struggling because
they told you to
um and I think that when you're dealing
with Cults that are dangerous
you're dealing with Cults where they
will tell you for example like a lot of
the ones that deal with pseudoscience
where here we have the cure for you so
people bypass actual cures things that
could really help them in order to get
what the cult leader or that person is
telling them they need and they end up
not doing well or they end up not living
but they've already signed their rights
away and so there's nothing that they
can do about it and so yes when you're
engaging in anything that feels like
someone's giving you the Cure
it can be potentially very very
dangerous and there can be a lot of
medical neglect actually in those
situations the other is when people are
finding themselves getting more
militaristic and they're talking about
the end times and they're talking about
survival that's when you get into a lot
more of the stockpiling of weapons of
also needing to see the world and the
people in it as less than as not human
anymore and that you're above them when
you have that polarization then you have
a lot of danger last thing generally
that I want to talk about and there's a
lot here is get getting people out right
we know when it comes to false beliefs
generally beating people over the head
with facts doesn't really work very well
you know we've had dozens of guests
where we talk about that in in one way
shape or form empathy is good
understanding is good communicating that
the person is not going to be shamed if
they decide oh you know what I was wrong
about this thing I want to get out
making clear that they're going to have
you know the resources if with
scientologists that's the big thing
where they have nothing and so part of
staying in is I'm going to have
literally nothing if I get out of here
um in terms of the getting out you
mentioned sometimes the people in The
Cult know the least about the cult I
don't necessarily need to one thing I
sometimes think about is in
conversations with Mormons and there's
different opinions about whether
Mormonism is a cult but let's at least
consider the possibility it might be
cult like many Mormons don't know that
Jose Smith each time he read the gold
tablets or whatever they are it was a
different reading and he had a history
of being a con man and all these
different things they just don't know
that and simply telling them that that's
a reality is not going to be convincing
if you just kind of give them that
information so what are the right ways
to communicate the information that they
might be lacking because we know just
like hey here's a bunch of stuff about
your beliefs doesn't really work
right I'm so glad you asked this
question because this is most of the
work that I do helping to have the
conversation that's difficult to have
with someone who might not be ready to
look at the fact that they were involved
in a cult
and also helping guide families and
friends and spouses to know how to have
these conversations so as not to kind of
you know push them farther back in and
make them feel alienated judged Etc
right so one of the things you want to
be able to do is you want to engage them
in a conversation about what they liked
about it let them know that you're going
to be fair-minded about this that there
must have been a reason that they got
involved what was the promise what did
they think they could get and maybe who
did they meet who they liked Etc so that
you're not just going in for the kill
you're not just going into talk about
what was bad because if you do then
they're going to feel foolish they're
going to feel like if it was all bad why
did I get involved why did I stay yeah
so talk about what they got or really
talk about what they were promised that
they probably still didn't get because
there's always the carrot that's dangled
so you get a sense of sort of what they
were searching for what is part of their
value system what they wanted to cure in
the world what they wanted to cure about
themselves
and then let them know that you have
information
and let them know that they can listen
to it or not they can disagree with it
or not but that this is information you
want to give to them out of respect for
them that this was something that was
kept from them but people should have
access to information so they can make a
fully informed decision and you let them
know that if they feel like they want to
go back they can go back
um there there have been plenty of times
that I've done an intervention where the
person has gone back but because I said
listen I'm glad you're saying that
you're not involved in a cult just in
case let me just give you a rundown of
what a cult is yeah and what happens
there and they could disagree with me in
the moment but they went back
it's like I planted a seed they went
back and they saw these things for
themselves so they could come out on
their own terms and so if the person
doesn't feel judged if they really are
able to maintain the sense that you see
them as capable you see them as bright
you see them as people who are not just
gullible people then you are going to be
able to have a much more successful
conversation and then say I have
information you can also share me and
share information with me about your
group and I will share information about
it too that I've heard so that there
really is a reciprocity to the
conversation
super interesting we've been speaking
with Rachel Bernstein who's an educator
therapist and author she also hosts the
weekly podcast indoctrination Rachel
really a pleasure having you on I
appreciate your time thank you so much
for having me on good to talk to you